foreign
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse live
stream podcast number wow did I forget
to look it up uh it is it does have a
number it is numbered it is numbered yes
we've decided to number these yes and
it's in the one still in the 160s
somewhere indeed indeed yeah yeah it's
162. 162. I think if my notes are
correct okay well I I presume your notes
are correct
um we'll mandate it we'll we'll uh we
buy Fiat it's number 162 no issue of
primeness
um I you are
it's a great point I am Dr Brett
Weinstein you are Dr Heather Hein and uh
we are uh we are here hosting we have
plenty to discuss I should tell you I am
not
as you well know not totally on my game
having just recovered from covid yes
Kobe do you remember coven
things you know I was gonna drop that
into our discussion here in a way that
was going to be surprising surprising
yeah okay well having just had coveted
it may still be surprising to me at
least
um not being entirely on my game
um
well I have stepped on uh on that
presentation but I will say
uh it is I had one
rough night treated it aggressively from
the get-go
uh spent five days in isolation I'm
feeling horsey uh I did not take horse
Pace proper but I certainly did take
some medications that are well
understood by those who well understand
things uh to to address coveted symptoms
be useful to uh treat a wide variety of
problems in both people and other
organisms including horses right
including horses right
um but anyway I will say I had a very
mild case it was quite annoying in the
sense of you know every time you get
sick with this disease you have to think
about how much
uh damage it does and although it's not
a very dangerous disease uh to those of
us who are healthy at this point it is
certainly does damage across a wide
number of systems which is troubling and
you know as we talked about extensively
at the beginning of the pandemic there
is this question those who called this
thing forth from a bat cave and enhanced
it have inflicted something on us
permanently and okay so maybe you get
covered every year or two and it
compromises a week of your life and
presumably for reasons that we will talk
about later on in the podcast uh
accelerates uh your rate of Aging across
multiple tissues I'm sorry is that can I
get a towel the cat just spilled a bunch
of water all over the deck
um this is not as bad as the pandemic
but it's bad I admit that I find my
computer maybe a bunch of fruits out
because I got a situation anyway well
it's just it's on the chords and so it's
just you can just throw it to me still
that we're good okay just go ahead what
were we talking about uh you were
talking about yes we were talking about
the tissue damage but anyway my point is
one of the things that I said early on
in our discussions was that the cost of
the pandemic no matter how mild this
disease gets
is effectively indefinitely large if we
let it get to the point that we are
permanently stuck with covid and that is
where we appear to be it is now people
even people we're stuck with it believed
that it might be addressed and driven to
Extinction early no longer believe that
I no longer think it's possible with
current Tech to drive it to Extinction
and so anyway there's a point about what
if we just take all of my future cases
of covid until I am gone from whatever
uh thing ultimately takes me out right
how many weeks of my life are going to
be compromised by somebody's idiotic
decision to engage and gain a function
research on uh bad coronaviruses right
that's a huge cost even just to me
personally and then if you scale that up
across all of the people of the earth
who are going to be suffering from
something even if it's just cold-like
right if you have seven more colds in
your life that are the result of Anthony
fauci right that's a pretty big cost for
one dude to inflict on you personally
um for his own idiot see yeah and that's
that's the the least of what might be
going on and that is the least and again
as I will discuss later on in the
podcast a proper model of the biology
underlying this says that it's not just
the weeks that you lose because you're
sick that is all borrowing from your
lifetime capacity to repair your own
tissues and so the point is it is
accelerating your rate of death the
reason most of us do not reach the
maximum human age is that over a
lifetime we spend the resources that
might get you to 120 fending off you
know flus damage all sorts of things and
uh and anyway so they have now added
another one even if it's a mild disease
that we get periodically and it's just
annoying the cost is still arbitrarily
huge
this is absolutely true and um and of
course it's also true that you know
it's hard to meet anyone now or to hear
of anyone really who hasn't had it at
this point and so you know many people
you know most people have some sort of a
mild case and and it's fine right they
appear to be fine
um with all of the caveats that you've
just made
um but even
then many many people will report
feeling like this isn't like other
viruses this isn't like either
respiratory infections that I've had it
feels different it feels it feels alien
in a way and you know of course it you
know it's it's a Franken virus so uh you
know that's not all that surprising but
the idea that it might it might just be
oh we've introduced another thing that's
going to circulate indefinitely and
you're going to be exposed to it and
you're going to get it indefinitely it's
really unlikely that it's going to be
that
that shallow a uh an impact so let's
just say uh what some of the stuff we're
going to talk about today
um are some um you've got a couple
little Clips uh from the uh the
excellent John Campbell to show and
discuss uh some of the implications uh
with regard to uh covet and the pandemic
I'd like to following that I'd like to
talk about a paper
um
paper that was published I guess it's
last month
uh purporting to show that while
infections covered infections are higher
after you've been vaccinated than after
you've had covet itself uh visits to
emergency rooms and hospitalizations and
deaths are higher among the UN among
those who have natural immunity but
aren't vaccinated as opposed to those
who are vaccinated so I just that seems
like a
that's certainly a very important result
if so and uh contradicts what a lot of
us have been suggesting so I want to
walk through that paper a little bit
and uh and then if we have time I'd be
interested in talking a little bit about
um stigma stigma and shame uh based on a
recent piece that I read and some things
that are sort of happening in in the
cultural space around around various
behaviors and predilections that people
have and uh it seems to have become
um
de facto accepted that if you say oh
well now you're shaming that person now
you're using shame that this is that
this is absolutely it's beyond the pain
it's an indictment in and of itself if
you're using shame then uh then
obviously we like we're done here and uh
I want to I want to explore that that
question uh and then you know probably
probably practically get us through a
lot of time and there's a few other
things we could talk about but but
probably won't
um so before we get into all that let's
do just a little top of the hour stuff
uh which is to say that we follow these
live streams normally we did not last
week but we are this week with the Q a
live q a you ask your questions at
darkhorsesemissions.com we also start
the Q a every week with a question from
our Discord Community our wonderful
Discord Community where they vote on a
question every week and that's where we
start
and if you're interested in being part
of that wonderful Community you can
access it at either of our patreons and
they have they have conversations in
text in audio in video they have uh
karaoke they have happy hour they have
book clubs there's a lot of great stuff
going on there and we encourage you to
check it out also at your patreon you
have conversations uh once a month two
two conversations once a month for the
higher tier patrons
and and we at my patreon do a monthly
private q a and right now you can ask
questions for the monthly private q a at
my patreon so that's some of the stuff
that's happening right now if you are
watching live you can watch on YouTube
uh YouTube did demonetize us so we get
there is no benefit to us any watching
on YouTube uh but uh we are also
streaming on Odyssey and that's what the
chat is if you want to join the chat
if you are looking for reading that
reminds you of what we're doing here we
of course wrote Hunter gather's Guide to
the 21st century which we encourage you
to to take a look at and I write weekly
at Natural Selections which is my sub
stack that's natural
selections.substike.com this week I
wrote about the explorations of salmon
uh including a little bit about the
Kokanee who are the sockeye salmon who
lose their Anatomy wow that was a lot of
words in one sentence that sound like
jargon so
Kokanee is is the word that we have
decided to use for this one species of
salmon Sockeye at the point that they
are no longer taking the journey out to
sea and spending most of their life
there and then returning to reproduce
and then die and that that life history
strategy of being born in freshwater and
going out to saltwater to live most of
your life and then returning back to
freshwater is called Anatomy or an
anadromous Lifestyle on the Kokanee and
it seems to have evolved a strategy
that's evolved multiple times in these
sockeye salmon have lost their Anatomy
they are effectively landlocked and even
in some cases maybe where the the the
the land lockedness has disappeared uh
the Kokanee lifestyle persists but
there's also some cases at least one
case swear
they were they were blocked by by a dam
and then there was an option to to move
out down river and some of them took it
and two years later right on schedule
some of them came right back so it's
like this toggle it's like genetic
toggle of a human Dam that was a human
Dam yeah that was not a beaver dam or a
salmon Dam which doesn't happen well the
thing is or just a like a like a
landslide damn I can't resist pointing
out that the reason that this Kokanee
strategy no you look like I'm setting
you up for a pun which as far as if I am
I have I'm even setting me up for it
because I don't know yet I don't feel
for you I do not feel your pain in this
regard no um the uh the strategy whereby
you lose your Anatomy that is you stop
going out to see
um is likely the result of the fact that
during glaciation many of these
waterways are blocked by uh ice dams and
so anyway it's not surprising in this
landscape which is so heavily modified
by glaciation even in during this
interglacial where you don't see the
causal effect the selection for the
ability to become landlocked and persist
that way and if you've got a really good
yes persist that way is is not
surprising yeah no and this is this is
analogous to
um
you know like this Mexican cave fish
that live in these systems where there
are underwater caves and um and
sometimes a cave will collapse and a
lineage that had lost its eyes is now
living in sunlight and the it's it's a
pretty easy toggle they can just become
I had again not individuals but you know
the Next Generation can have eyes when
when their parents didn't but you would
not expect that to exist in some in some
lineage in which something happened that
doesn't repeat throughout history yeah
uh where you know oh okay the eyes were
just a hazard no help they lost them
because getting poked in the eye is a
you know is a risk and so they don't
have eyes anymore oh my good goodness
the light came back well there's going
to be some lineages where there's that
flexibility that plasticity does not
um does not persist
all right so um excuse me you can also
get I was trying to mop up the uh error
from the cat with this lovely tote bag
the air from the caffeine water for
those of you joining late yeah so it's
just water he's just not but um here's
the other cat this is the Epic Tabby
um tote bag which we've got at our store
at darkhorsestore.com
org
um and uh there's lots of good stuff
there
okay
um
the only thing remaining before we get
into the meat of the show is our
sponsors who with whom we are so pleased
and very and
about which we are very grateful I I
lost we are very
grateful yes we're being grateful that
you guys now thank you okay we've got
three three ads at the top of the hour
as usual that's the wrong piece of paper
Just Go With It there anything terrible
on it it's the notes for the show I just
don't think it's gonna be the same thing
um okay
our first sponsor this week has become a
favorite here at Dark Horse it's House
of macadamias that's right nuts tree
nuts are delicious and nutritious
they're generally high in fat and low in
carbohydrates which is increasingly
understood to be both satiating and good
for you but each species of nut is
different and for many of us macadamias
are the best macadamia nuts take a very
long time to grow however and because
they are both rare and highly sought
after they have the dewiest distinction
of being the world's most expensive nut
between the taste and the health
benefits though they're worth it they
have fewer carbohydrates and than most
other nuts for instance half of what
cashews or pistachios have and
two-thirds of what almonds have which
makes them the perfect snack for
breaking a daily fast and controlling
blood glucose they're also uniquely rich
in omega-7s including especially
palmitoleic acid an unsaturated fat that
has been linked to Natural collagen
production fat loss and heart health and
as we've said before I've got the
references right here in case you guys
want those House of macadamia's intent
on making this amazing food accessible
to everyone they've partnered with more
than 90 farmers in Africa and now make
one-of-a-kind vegan keto and paleo
snacks these include the dark chocolate
dipped macadamias and a delicious
assortment of bars made with 45
macadamia nuts in flavors including
salted caramel and chocolate coconut our
favorites are the Simply Delicious
salted macadamias made with namibian sea
salt they are amazing we love them and
think that you will too
our house of academias Highly recommends
House of macadamias for all of your
macadamic needs looking for something
nourish and energizing while in pursuit
of the truth or while climbing the next
Summit well go to
www.houseofmacademias.com and use code
Darkhorse for a 20 discount on every
order that you make not just your first
one plus star course listeners will
receive a complimentary four ounce bag
of macadamias when they order three or
more boxes of any Macadamia product once
again that's www.house of macadamias
that's
m-a-c-a-d-a-m-i-a-s.com use code
Darkhorse for 20 off every order you
won't be sorry so here's a question for
you all right uh adaptively speaking
slowest growing nut why would that be
and that's my thought Yeah you mentioned
something there
no no just a very long time to grow very
long time driving all right maybe not
slow and I don't and that doesn't
necessarily mean slow is growing out it
may just mean a long time to set to set
seed or to to set
um irregardless okay here regardless
here's the Adaptive hypothesis for you
because they grow in such marvelous
locations waiting isn't a problem ah you
see what I'm saying yeah they're also
really delicious when they're done so
you know yeah it's a big reward yeah you
get to hang out in this beautiful place
while you're waiting The Waiting isn't
so bad exactly now you're seeing it okay
now you're there I feel like the people
at House of macadamias know this they
probably do yeah and yes and I envy them
if they yeah work where these things
grow yeah
all right our second sponsor this week
is mud water mud water is a coffee
alternative made with four medicinal
mushrooms plus herbs and spices with 1 7
the caffeine is a cup of coffee you get
energy without the anxiety Jitters or
crash of coffee and it's delicious if
you like the routine of making and
drinking a cup of warmth in the morning
but don't drink coffee or trying to cut
down on your caffeine try mud water
maybe you resolve to drink less coffee
in the new year but are realizing
halfway through February that it's not
quite working
if you're looking for a different way to
kick off your day
a delicious warming enhancing way that
isn't just a caffeine Rush try mud water
each ingredient to mud water was added
with intention it has cacao and chai
lion's mane mushrooms cordyceps chaga
and reishi turmeric and cinnamon but
water also makes
yes you have something to say
okay our mud water does not make
anything for the cats which apparently
is what is upsetting Tesla right now
mud water however makes a number of
delicious things for people including a
non-dairy creamer out of coconut milk
and MCT add a sweetener out of coconut
palm sugar and lucuma which is the fruit
of an Andean tree used by the Inca you
can add either of those if you prefer
those options you can also mix and match
maybe add a bit of their coconut milk
and MCT creamer which is really quite
good with some honey from your favorite
bees or if you don't have favorite bees
get some honey from your favorite
beekeeper and if you don't have a
favorite beekeeper I suggest you get one
we don't have one though
where's the penny will soon I hope so or
use mud actually I think we do
I think we have we have a friend we have
a friend who keeps bees outside of
Austin yes yes in in an ape apiarist
he is an apiarist yes yes as most
beekeepers are
as far as I know um
let's see there's some um
yeah many guys don't really keep me no
they don't honey badgers not so much
yeah okay so all the APA apiarists are
Apes I think okay or use mud Waters
lucuma and coconut palm sugar sweetener
and skip the bees entirely and you can
just skip this entire part of this
conversation if you do that mud water
slaver is warm and spicy with a hint of
chocolate plus Masala chai which
includes Ginger and cardamom nutmegs and
cloak nutmegs nutmeg and cloves it's
also delicious blended into a smoothie
try it I recommend this with banana ice
milk or your favorite milk-like
substance mint and cacao nibs fresh mint
cacao nibs yum really really good mud
water is 100 USDA organic non-GMO
gluten-free vegan and kosher certified
and it allows you to build a morning
ritual that promotes sustained energy
without the crash so visit mudwater.com
Darkhorse to support the show and use
code Dark Horse Mud at checkout for 15
off that's Dark Horse Mud that's
m-u-d-w-tr.com Darkhorse
use Dark Horse Mud at checkout for 15
off and here's a protein
for those who actually like the anxiety
of coffee but want to do away with the
rest they can have mud water and then
what you do is you sprinkle Legos in the
carpet and you turn down the lights and
that gives you the anxiety without any
of the other downsides of coffee
all right our final sponsor this week is
MD hearing aid which makes high quality
simple effective hearing aids for a tiny
fraction of what most hearing aids cost
helping bring audio Clarity and capacity
to people who might not otherwise be
able to afford it MD hearing aid was
founded by an ENT surgeon who made it
his mission to develop a quality hearing
aid that anyone could afford he kept the
price Low by simplifying the product
removing several rarely needed
components and he made a product that
aims to fit so well that no one will
know you're wearing it
other features include rechargeable
batteries that last up to 30 hours water
resistance and up to three feet of water
and the volt plug on the volt plus model
and you don't need a prescription to get
one MD hearing aid has cut out the
middleman so you buy your hearing aid
directly from the source where
audiologists and licensed hearing
Specialists are available seven days a
week
everyone can empathize with what it
feels like to be left out of a
conversation that others are enjoying
here's a testimonial from a friend of
ours who has substantial hearing loss
and who relies on hearing aids we asked
her to try this product and here's what
she said quote with my particular type
of hearing loss a deep male voice in a
noisy room is the hardest situation for
me to hear and understand speech I wore
the MD hearing aid to have a
conversation with a deep voiced male in
a room with a lot of white noise the MD
hearing aid passed the test as my
conversation partner's voice was clear
and understandable at a price point
price point of under a thousand dollars
I was amazed at how effective they are
end quote
MD hearing aid is bringing affordable
hearing to hundreds of thousands of
people who might not otherwise be able
to afford high quality hearing aids get
Clinic level care for 90 less with MD
hearing aid which offers a 45-day
risk-free trial and money back guarantee
go to mdhearingaid.com and use the promo
code Darkhorse to get their new buy one
get one deal a pair of hearing aids cost
just 149.99 plus Dark Horse listeners
receive a free extra charging case a
hundred dollar value
so head to MD hearing aid
md-h-e-a-r-i-n-g-a-i-d.com and use the
promo code Darkhorse to get their new
buy one get one deal a pairing a pair of
hearing aids for only 149.99
oh here we are
here we are uh so to the to the meat of
the show
who wanted to start I believe yeah I
wanted to do a couple things and I let
me uh frame this properly here I think
one of the things that we learn in
watching how our material goes into the
world what sort of impact it has on
people what sorts of challenges come
back at us one of the things that we
learn
is how our understanding of the way
something like science functions is
different from what most people think
and you know to us the bread and butter
of science uh is in the predictive power
but even that doesn't quite explain what
science is and why it works the way it
does and in order to really understand
its role in Civilization it's its role
in pushing civilization forward one has
to get into the nitty-gritty of the
philosophy of science what is the
product and so in any case I want to get
at the question of what is the product
by looking back at some
things that I and we have said over the
course of the pandemic that now exist in
a very different light as a result of
work that has emerged very late in this
case I want to talk about a couple of
things that were discussed by John
Campbell who is uh well I will speak
only for myself but he's one of my
favorites during the pandemic he's
extremely rigorous and careful and he
manages to navigate some of the most
difficult territory in the pandemic
um with uh
a spectacular aplomb shall we say
um so anyway my overarching point is
going to be that the product of science
the good product the thing that we want
the reason that we go through the effort
of science is not what you think it is
the product of science is not data the
product of science isn't even evidence
or experimental results the product of
science is models
now I have to add a caveat right there
because you and I have said some very
disparaging things about models they're
a different kind of model the model to
be super cautious about are computer
models right where you put in to a
computer that oversimplifies especially
the biotic world
some sort of a set of algorithms you
feed it something that is like uh data
and then it spits out a projection of
what's going to happen a climate model
might be a very sophisticated uh
computer mechanism for predicting future
temperature and they are fraught with
danger because uh what those who build
models know is that the more complex a
model is the easier it is for it to
mirror some behavior for completely the
wrong reasons so although it looks like
an accurate rendition of the world it is
not capable at all of predicting
anything accurately about the future
because it is basically just mapping on
to the past and then the your assumption
will be that it will work in the future
so I'm not I'm not talking about
computer models go ahead oh just the
fewer the fewer inputs a model has the
broader it will be and the less
predictive it will be even if the inputs
are entirely accurate and so it doesn't
have as as uh as much utility the more
inputs it has the more narrow it's going
to be and the more likely some of the
inputs are to be wrong or maybe most to
the point here which is what I thought
you were going to say your inputs are
inherently riddled with whatever
assumptions you have and you know you we
are we're trying always in science to
figure out ways to reduce bias and
because we are human beings always doing
the science who have bias and who cannot
completely Escape our own bias we are
looking to uh we are looking to control
for that bias but what you plug into a
model will be based on what assumptions
you have and so it is
um often disingenuous for people to say
my goodness look what that model just
spit out when in fact what it's spit out
is exactly the biases you plugged into
it in the first place right that is one
of one of the ways that a a model can
appear to be accurate and yet be
inaccurate in the sense that it predicts
nothing going forward that it Maps
properly onto
onto the past
um For No Good Reason
um so
you want the simplest if you were going
to do computer models you want the
simplest model that manages to predict
something going forward but the
predicting going forward is the key and
what what I have said is the only valid
use of a computer model is not to test
something but it is to create a
hypothesis which you would then need to
go and test in the empirical world but
put that aside the point here is the
product of science the correct product
of science
are models that work right and I don't
mean computer models I mean models like
a model of the atom in which something
called electrons have a negative charge
they orbit a nucleus which is positively
charged composed of two components they
orbit in something called orbital shells
which have different shapes and this is
not an exact description of the of the
atom but what it is is a highly
predictive model of an out of an atom
that tells you a lot of what will happen
when you combine atoms in different uh
combinations and ratios under a wide
range of conditions and then at some
point the difference between the model
and whatever the underlying reality is
causes you not to be able to predict
certain things and that's where we are
with something like the excellent model
of the atom we have it's imperfect but
it's very good for most circumstances so
like those orbital shells like shell is
metaphor and it is
um you know it's it's not it is almost
certainly not true that it it's in these
sort of like concentric
spheres going out from from the nucleus
uh but it works up to a point and then
at the point that it stops being
predictive or you start throwing errors
when you put different parts of of the
model against one another then you know
you need an upgrade right and
um you know even electron right an
electron is a thing or what sort of a
thing is it well even that has a degree
of metaphor to it right so sophisticated
versions of the atom treat the position
of the electron not as a point but as a
probability and so the point is your
models have to get more and more
elaborate in order to deal with the
subtle nuances
um and you know we see this again and
again Newtonian physics is a model of
the universe that works really well at
low speeds
um but you know it breaks down at higher
uh levels but anyway the point is it's
the model do you want to figure out
what's going to happen on a pool table
when you input forces in a particular
Way Newton in physics is a good model
right it'll tell you what happens on a
pool table pretty pretty effectively
but in science we have to push the
models farther and farther in order to
predict the really subtle stuff
and I did want to give one example a
famous example of how the product of
science is not the uh the data right
it's the models and I was going to use
Einstein's prediction about the effect
that gravity has on light right it is
very counterintuitive that light should
be affected by gravity because this
effect is so weak that in normal space
we don't experience anything that is
remotely affected by it right in fact
the Earth isn't really big enough to
have this effect you need something
gigantic like the sun to exert enough of
this very weak Force to actually impinge
on life sufficiently that you could
measure it
the point is the test of relativity
involved the requirement of an Eclipse
which happened in 1919 okay two
Expeditions were sent to remote places
where the eclipse would be total one of
them was an island off of Africa I
believe one of them was Brazil and the
idea was if Einstein is correct about
relativity and that doesn't mean
perfectly correct but it means more
correct than the model he proposes to
replace then the following thing will be
true the position that we know for the
stars that are right behind the position
of the sun will be altered by the sun's
presence that's true with or without the
eclipse but you can't see it because the
sun is so bright you need the eclipse to
darken the sun in order for you to see
the stars moved as a result of the
gravitational lensing of the light
bending around the Sun
so
all the scientists knew that this was a
prediction of the model yeah they can't
very well create an eclipse they can't
work with anything smaller than the sun
in order so there's no Eclipse right and
so the point is hey guess what natural
experiment it's coming but we need to be
in the right place we got one only one
option until until 1930 something right
actually 1937 I think I think but anyway
so the point is okay natural experiment
um they send these two Expeditions lo
and behold the position of the Stars
moves exactly as Einstein predicts that
it will based on what we understand to
be the size of the sun and its
gravitational force hooray
but the change in the position of the
Stars when the sun happens to be right
there in the sky and the moon happens to
be blocking the light is useless
there's no value to it all it is is
evidence that this model that Einstein
proposes is correct now once you have a
model of Relativity that's correct then
all sorts of other things flow from the
existence of that now improved model
including things and I'd be hard-pressed
to explain how it works but things like
GPS depend on small relativistic
differences in order to precisely
pinpoint your position on the earth I
didn't know that
um I hope that's true as always you will
find out if I've got it wrong but
nonetheless the point is relativity has
huge implications it doesn't affect a
baseball game it doesn't affect
Billiards it doesn't affect you know
most of the stuff we do down here on
Earth but there are things that we do
that now are impacted by it and
certainly our understanding of the
universe and how big it is and in what
way it moves is uh all affected
dramatically by this input so the point
is the product of that whole scientific
process that that Einstein went through
where he hypothesized relativity and
then it was demonstrated through eclipse
point of that was not data it was not
even evidence the point of that was hey
if he's right about the eclipse nothing
else predicts that his model it's not
exactly right necessarily but the point
is his model contains some kind of truth
that we didn't have before and that
means well now we can extrapolate from
it about other things right because we
have a reason to believe it contains a
big chunk of the truth
which brings me of course and obviously
to John Campbell awesome right
so all right we're going to start with
um
a paper that John Campbell reviews in
the last week or so that is actually the
report on a single autopsy of a
gentleman I believe a British gentleman
who died after covet vaccination if I
recall correctly it had three mRNA shots
and anyway so this is a autopsy report
that his family was concerned that his
death did not appear to make sense he
was in his 70s
um can you show that uh clip from John
Campbell
it's the autopsy one
it's yes okay
so we can say definitively this damage
was caused by vaccine not by the natural
infection let's have a look at the proof
for that now
so here we see the SARS coronavirus 2
virus that we're familiar with the spike
protein here of course now the spike
protein can occur on the virus itself or
the Sprite protein is also generated by
the vaccine
but the nucleocapsid protein is inside
It's associated with the RNA the actual
ribonucleic acid of the of the virus and
the nucleocapsic protein is only found
in the virus it's never generated by a
vaccine
so if you see Spike protein on its own
that means it's vaccine if you see Spike
protein and nucleocapsid protein it
means it's natural viral infection
that's the difference between the two
now in this first slide we're looking at
the the frontal part of the brain and we
can see patches of degeneration and
inflammation
on this next picture we can actually see
acute brain damage as well whenever
there's a one that's a death of a nerve
cell neuronal death and two is
microglial infiltration these are the
defense cells in the brain and three are
lymphocytes which are associated with
viral infection and of course all of
these are pathological findings none of
them should be there
is that where you want me to go yep
okay so
um I'm not going to translate this into
English because John Campbell speaks
English probably better than I do but I
am going to translate it into slightly
less technical language so people can
get the full impact here
what we have is evidence of substantial
that is to say visible on microscope
slide brain damage in this now deceased
patient
and the question is why
what they found is
Spike protein
in the area of damage that's conspicuous
but that potentially has two different
explanations
the vaccines produce Spike protein and
the virus obviously produces Spike
protein
so in and of itself that could be
consistent with either
but what they in fact find is that Spike
protein is present and another protein
nucleocapsid protein which we have
discussed before nucleocapsid protein
being proteins associated with the
genetic content of the virus is
completely absent even though in normal
virus nucleocapsid protein is actually
more prevalent than Spike so were this
the result of a cryptocovet infection it
would be that both proteins were present
and in fact what we have is only the
protein produced by the virus itself but
further and this is the point this is
the reason I'm using this uh particular
clip from Campbell uh in conjunction
with this discussion of models further
what is shown in these microscope slides
and in this report is the presence of T
lymphocytes at the site of a brain
damage right you've got dead neurons
here you've got Spike protein you've got
microglial cells and you've got T
lymphocytes okay now all of that is
actually the validation of the
hypothesis that I put on the table I
will have to look up when it would have
been the first time I discussed it but I
presented a model for vaccine damage to
the body
we've talked about it a number of times
since but the model says you've got
lipid nanoparticles
that coat an mRNA message that encodes
Spike protein
those lipid nanoparticles
coding this
genetic message do not stay local to the
injection site at least in some people
but probably all people they escape into
the circulatory system they float around
the body and conspicuously
the vaccine manufacturers have no
targeting mechanism whatsoever which
means they will be taken up by cells I
don't want to say randomly because it
may not be random but arbitrarily cells
that the vaccine manufacturers did not
choose in any way they didn't specify
them as cells that you could afford to
lose and therefore could afford to make
this message and then suffer the
consequences and so what that means
is that they will be taken up by cells
in the circulatory system
very conspicuously in the heart and then
something terrible will very predictably
happen
that very terrible thing is that the
immune system will spot the cells of
your own body producing a foreign
protein and they will make the only
conclusion that your immune system could
possibly make in that situation because
that is exactly the marker for a viral
infection where your cells have been
hijacked by a pathogen
and they start producing foreign
proteins and then the point is in such a
case there's no rescuing such a cell
once it has taken up this foreign
message killing that cell even though
that's bad is better than the
alternative that's what the immune
system is designed to do right that's
what it's for right hundreds of millions
of years of evolution have built it to
spot this very common phenomenon and to
deal with it in the unfortunate but best
way possible which is to kill off the
cells that have been infected and so by
creating a pseudo-infection which is
what these mRNA vaccines are
they are effectively painting a Target
on cells in your body whichever ones
take up the lipid nanoparticle message
a particle coded message
they are targeting them for Destruction
and autoimmune destruction of your own
cells and worse
this would be a temporary phenomenon but
they stabilize the damn mrnas so that
they don't go out of functionality and
return the cells to an innocuous
presentation that then stops triggering
the immune system so anyway here what
John Campbell has revealed and what that
little clip shows
is low and bold all of the things that
you would predict from that model which
I spelled out are true you have uh so
the thing that you haven't said yet the
connection is that the T lymphocytes
there in the brain next to the
um obvious brain damage is an indication
that they that they were there
um looking for cells that were spouting
viral
um viral messages viral message so here
you have damaged you if you have a
person who did not have an infection of
the brain we don't see any evidence of
that here what they had was a pseudo
infection of the brain with
the MRNA messages encoded in the MRNA
vaccines that was apparently transcribed
in the brain into Spike protein caused
the immune system to freak out as of
course it would to then target cells and
kill them and you have all of the all
you know the only thing we don't have is
a live movie of this happening what we
have is all of the consequences that you
would expect all here in a you know in a
static microscope slide and the point is
look
That vaccine wasn't supposed to reach
the brain right it wasn't supposed to
get into the brain that's already a
major design flaw
having reached the brain it shouldn't be
particularly prone to transfect those
cells but of course how would it not
it's a dumb particle it's just covered
in fat it's going to transfect whatever
cells will absorb it and so here you've
got a case and yeah it's only one case
but nonetheless you've got a guy who has
an a vaccine injury that has produced
brain damage that has left its signature
making it unmistakably the consequence
of vaccine Spike protein and not coveted
Spike protein and you have the obvious
activation of the white blood cells
countering what they must think to the
extent that they behave like they think
is an infection so let me just try to um
steal me in the opposition here
um is there are there any known cases of
SARS kovi 2 in the body
the spike protein uh gets loose can the
spike protein uh travel on its own in
the body do we have any cases of that I
think the answer is no but so you know
if it could then then you would see that
signature that is otherwise a vaccine
signature uh somewhere and I think that
that's the only way though that this
that this
indication this you know this this
Smoking Gun of either there's Spike
protein and nucleocapsid protein in
evidence in the place where the damage
is or if there's only Spike protein then
it's vaccine injury if there's both
um it's it's virus injury it unless the
spike protein can never disassociate
from the virus uh in in Vivo well I
wouldn't bet that it does all the time
because the you know the mechanism uh if
you get
to take the unusual nature of sarsko V2
out of the picture you get an infection
with a coronavirus it invades some cells
it causes those cells to produce foreign
protein they build cells produce new
virus which goes around infecting your
own cells trying to get out of you into
somebody else but what happens is as the
immune system gets better and better at
recognizing uh the infected cells it
does break them apart and so right
almost so fragments fragments but but if
it's really if it's just like broken
apart fragments you it can't it doesn't
have any ability to
mobilize well it shouldn't be Spike and
no nucleocaps you could imagine a weird
ratio you could imagine the spike
protein is more durable and so the
nuclear capsule proteins get broken up
at a higher rate but they're produced in
higher numbers to begin with yeah they
shouldn't be getting into the brain in
the first place right sure but that's a
different question it may or may not be
right so the point is you've got a
pathology that flows from these mRNA
vaccinations one of the things that we
talked about for which I believe
actually we were attacked by PolitiFact
I hope I'm not sure it was PolitiFact
but somebody claimed to have fact
checked us on this was the blood brain
barrier question about the fragmentation
of the blood-brain barrier from the
spike protein in the dam so-called
vaccines so anyway the point is look is
this proof positive no
but proof positive isn't a scientific
thing what this is is a bunch of
different predictions of a model
that show up in a case
right and then the point is is this as
good as you know an eclipse proving
relativity no but what it is is it's
damn good evidence that that model was
capable of looking into the future and
predicting the results of somebody's
autopsy right okay so given that and to
get more um evidence of the of similar
unlike in physics we don't have to wait
almost 20 years right and okay so then
here's my unlike in that particular
instantiation physics right well that
weird very famous case yeah here's my
point okay the payoff of all of this
is not even the model OKAY the model is
great the fact that we now have a model
that says not only do we have an effect
right this isn't correlation equals
causation this is oh here's a model that
predicts damage in an individual right
okay but now the payoff comes from the
extrapolation now we can go back to that
model and we can say okay if this model
overlaps the truth substantially which I
think is probably the correct way to say
it right what else does it tell us
oh well here are the other things it
tells us it tells us that you have a
completely indiscriminate transfection
agent that is going to cause your own
immune system to damage tissues
arbitrarily around the body and the
effect of that will be that this isn't
it's not causing myocarditis yes it
causes myocarditis but myocarditis is
going to be one on a long list of
pathologies most of which or maybe all
of which are more subtle in which
various tissues around the body
are damaged by your own immune system
responding to this vaccine being
effective in places that the
manufacturer either didn't anticipate or
wasn't honest about so what you mean
when you say it doesn't cause
myocarditis is
that myocarditis and pericarditis
being injuries to muscle associated with
the heart myo or the pericardium the
membrane around the heart Perry
um
are going to reveal themselves more
easily because of the fact that the
heart does not have repair capacity it's
the breads earlier work on telomeres and
cancer and senescence right and so
that's what we're going to see first
that does not mean that it's the only
damage that's happening by a long shot
the I the the model says and here we
have evidence supporting the model with
what you have revealed from John
Campbell here that the damage will be
everywhere
depending on the particulars of you know
whether your shot was aspirated how
healthy you were at the time how healthy
you are in general exactly you know what
you know where it went in your body and
what other viral load you might have had
at the time etc etc like all sorts of
things are going to affect what tissues
in you may have gotten affected but were
there tissues that were affected
um a hundred percent because actually
that's the mechanism of action of the
thing right that's like that's that's
the intended mechanism of action of the
MRNA vaccines is that they will
transfect some cells and then your
immune system will come in and learn
from them and figure out how to prevent
future infection which of course we now
know doesn't work right and in fact uh
if you were to go to that before we had
this particular result if you were to
say well you know basically going to
nail all tissues maybe not yeah right
there may be tissues which for whatever
molecular reason don't take up banana
particle very well you could have little
or no damage I don't know that there are
such tissues but there could be right
but if I was going to say yeah where
would you expect an exception the brain
might be most likely because of the
blood brain barrier but the point is uh
here you have it you have the exact
prediction of this model which suggests
that this is going to be happening
you're going to have itises all over the
body and the itises aren't just
inflammation that is inflammation that
is Downstream of damage and the point is
okay you can basically now name your
pathology because you're talking about
you know gee which tissues are perfused
with blood virtually all of them right
right right so the point is you can in
principle get damaged just about
anywhere and so
you know the other thing that we now
have to look at is
how did we end up you know this has been
a very painful educational process
figuring out what exactly they were
proposing and what exactly it suggested
might be the hazards but now that we
know now that we can look back
this technology at no business being
utilized in people right not because
I've been trying for so long Brett not
because it isn't brilliant in principle
it solves a major problem a gene therapy
problem which is how do you get enough
genes into enough cells to actually
treat a pathology okay that's a
difficult problem well it also solves a
um time of onset of a time of
realization there's a pathogen to uh to
there's a realization of the treatment
yeah problem the times the time scale is
is remarkable and you can imagine you
can imagine people who have a financial
interest in this technology thinking
damn we are so close this this thing is
really incredibly capable if we can just
get past a couple hurdles oh what will
it take oh about 50 years to solve the
targeting problem and get through the
regulatory proof that we've solved it
well enough that we're not going to kill
huge numbers of people right can you
wait 50 years no I'll be dead can you
get it to me sooner
um and so that's the question is did
they utilize a global emergency
to fast forward to get us not to notice
that they had a targeting problem they
couldn't solve right and to get this
technology so mainstreamed that it's now
like oh well you know get ready we're
going to start doing flu vaccines with
the MRNA Tech really you still haven't
solved the problem and the fact that
goes the model the model that I
presented right the model that we now
have
some evidence turns out to be predictive
of things like autopsy results that
model
says actually the pathology
nothing to do with covet
yes it's bad that they chose Spike
Protein that's bad Spike protein has its
own added pathologies
so you mean the pathology from the
vaccine yes the vaccine pathology is
simply about foreign proteins produced
indiscriminately by human cells that
then get targeted by the immune system
right and so the point is okay now you
want to tell me you want to do other
shots with this platform that it's so
marvelous you still haven't solved the
main problem that should have prevented
you from injecting this into any people
at all right you still haven't solved it
and now you're like what else can we use
it for right so
it's it's mind-blowing that we would be
there but that that is where we are and
anyway I do want to go back and just
emphasize
the fact that the model says heart
damage may be noticed first heart damage
may be more serious because it's your
damn heart right it's not some big
necrosis in your liver that you might
well survive or not even notice right
this is your heart any damage to it is
serious right
um it's not just that but uh the fact is
this is a
destroyer of future capacity for repair
right so the fact that myocarditis is
predictive of other itises that are
actually the result of damage not just
inflammation across the body is the
payload right now we need to look for
these things and we need to figure out
um
a how to minimize the damage that's
already been done to protect the people
who have had these things right maybe we
need to engage in some new kind of
scanning to find damage that may catch
these people unaware anyway it's a
yeah
the payload is the model the model
predicts things well beyond the heart
and it is time for us to now be paying
attention uh because the evidence is uh
quite clear and really also the onus is
on those who say well it's one patient
right it's not really very much evidence
well no now the burden of proof is on
you to prove that that patient was
highly anomalous rather than this is now
something that we do see when we look
elsewhere right you can't use the fact
of not looking as a as a falsification
how about we begin
um autopsies of um people who've
experienced Unexpected death
which we absolutely should have been
doing and we're resisting doing for some
reason deeply buried in the uh the
catacombs of Public Health right right
so you had another video you wanted to
show yeah if you can
I thought that was part of this but if
you want to wait until later we can do
that no no uh let's uh let's introduce
that one here so this is actually a
separate John Campbell video on a
separate topic also I believe in this
last week
um in which he and again he is among the
most careful analysts of the covet
pandemic that I'm aware of
um but this one is quite shocking and
also matches a different prediction uh
in a way it's not quite as clear-cut but
I I think you'll um I think you'll see
it hey Zach can you yep you ready uh
yeah
out of their guidelines here
now this is managing breathlessness so
this was published remember on the 3rd
of April 2020.
and they say this consider an opioid and
a benzodiazepine
now um
what they mean there is an opium-based
drug like morphine and the bendo
benzodiazepine they talk about is
midazolam
now this is a classical well tried
trusted form of treatment that we use
for things like terminal agitation part
of terminal care when people are dying
of conditions such as cancer and things
that are incurable to manage a peaceful
death and it's completely the right
thing to do in the vast majority of
circumstances
but what seemed to happen was nice just
took that and transposed that into the
covered situation and covert of course
we know is an infection and most people
can get completely better from it
was this a fundamental
all right
um
what Joanna Campbell says here is that
and this is a British
memo that he is unearthing here a
British member from uh April of 2020. in
which a recommendation was made for the
treatment of patients who have very
serious effects from uh covet these are
hospitalized people who are clearly in
Jeopardy of death
the memo suggests the application of a
two drug protocol one an opioid
um like morphine and the other
benzodiazepine like midazolam
and his point is this is shocking to
hear because that combination is well
understood and properly used in medicine
in patients who have a terminal disease
at the very end of their pathology
that this is effectively palliative care
that uh
allows life to be ended by prioritizing
comfort in a patient for which there is
actually no medical hope
and what John Campbell says here is this
doesn't make sense in the context of a
coveted patient no matter how close to
death they appear because what they are
sick with is an infectious agent that
they might fend off right the fact is we
have what people do yeah we have all had
the experience
of being very very very sick and then
suddenly being on the mend and headed in
the right direction and what has
happened is your immune system has
figured out the formula sufficiently
well that you go from a trajectory that
if you followed it far enough would take
you to death right and suddenly your
trajectory is in the upward direction
and you may not feel great but you feel
a hell of a lot better because you're on
the mend the the infection is being
reduced and his point is look that
happens in people so it does not ever
make sense uh to
give a patient a
deadly if compassionate pair of drugs in
the case that what they're sick with is
an infectious agent that they actually
might beat
and I will say the title of his video
involves the term euthanasia which
I struggled with a little bit because
this is an official memo suggesting a
use of this drug cocktail this isn't the
case in which somebody has said well
this patient you know
uh should be
humanely put out of their misery this is
just medical recommendations that result
in the same thing now I don't know
whether that's an accident or not but I
will say there's a segment those who
watched my last Joe Rogan uh discussion
1919 there's a section in there in which
I've become uncomfortable and I actually
discuss my discomfort I say you will
hear me hesitating to say this but I
can't help but wonder I say something
like I keep revisiting the part of the
pandemic in which we are applying
ventilators to desperately ill people
ventilators that we later came to
understand were doing more harm than
good they were actually killing people
and my thought the thing that I was
struggling to express to Joe was
that one of the effects of using
ventilators as the standard of care for
patients who they actually harmed was
that it drove up the number of people
who plausibly died of covet and so from
the point of view of justifying a
Draconian response to covid it made
covid look that much worse than it
actually was and again I'm not saying
covet isn't a terrible disease I think
it's much more dangerous than the case
fatality rate suggests but nonetheless
driving the number of
dead from covid people up did cause all
of the panic that then ensued that
caused us to lock down and do ourselves
damage that way to mass children all of
the things that we did
we're Downstream of the implication of
the desperate seriousness of this
disease and we were induced to think
this by many things including fraudulent
video out of China that misrepresented
uh you know people dying on the street
this sort of thing so
anyway this is not as secure as a
autopsy result that matches a
mechanistic model
um of the pathology that arises from
mRNA vaccination but it is another place
where a prediction
um is now manifest in other words I
didn't see this drug combination thing
coming but it is perfectly consistent
right the idea that uh a standard of
care that increases the number of people
who die of covid was not just one thing
it wasn't just ventilators it was also
uh apparently the at least in Britain
the prescription of this combination of
drugs and who knows how many other
things
which is also consistent with a total
failure to advise people about the
hazard of vitamin D deficiency a total
failure to apply the drugs that we had
that actually uh were highly effective
against many uh mRNA viruses
like uh like Ivermectin so anyway it is
again part of this pattern that is very
hard to
um
very hard to miss once you see it we do
all sorts of things that appear to have
increased harm rather than decreased
harm and you could imagine medicine is a
difficult business sometimes you're
going to do something thinking it will
be helpful and it turns out to be the
opposite but when you start doing that
across the board you do everything
that's unhelpful it raises a question
about why that happened yeah no and it
goes It goes on and on and on as you say
you know locking people in their homes
um
away from the Sun away from the ability
to do physical activity
I recently ran into again a picture I
think maybe out of Italy somewhere of
the police scooping up sunbathers
because because those were the people
who were at risk and putting other
people at risk right being alone outside
catching the Rays and generating vitamin
D
and
um
you know we had as as obesity became
clearly a comorbidity for this disease
and a really strong one and we talked
about some of the really remarkable
evidence for that we had a Resurgence of
the idea of fat shaming as the problem
right it's it's and again you know maybe
we'll get there later in this episode
but like it's the it's the people who
are shaming others
um that is the epidemic here
it's it's not the fact that actually
there are going to be regardless of
whether you like it or not or think it's
fair or not
mechanisms by which this virus is acting
in your body that allows it to do more
damage if you have a lot of fat on you
it's not that shaming
it's not yeah I remember uh
the sheer number of places where
even just a basic understanding of covet
and how it transmits would have not only
given you a different prescription but
the inverse was stunning and I remember
you and I looking at each other I I
think I remember a image that we showed
probably have a newspaper article
discussing how they were closing down
the trails and the state parks and the
beaches right and we're just thinking
you're actually gonna harm people
because if they're not outside
they're going home to an environment
where somebody may have coveted and
they're going to catch it whereas if
they had been outside at that time they
would have virtually no risk playground
strung with caution tape
for months and months and months
children weren't allowed to play on
playgrounds I believe they literally put
sand in skate parks yes
I mean yeah that's just ludicrous I mean
that's that's like almost uh
for a little while their skateboarding
was a crime wow yeah how did we not see
that yeah um but you're right they made
skateboarding a crime
um and just the sort of
um
anti-fun you know and kids weren't
threatened by Cove in the first place
right and you're pouring sand in their
damn skate park right you're screwing up
their world they can't go anywhere
they're not going to school you're going
to take their skate park from them with
sand like yeah you're just a terrible
person that's right
that's right
um so I did have two last things that I
forgot to say I want to I just add in
here so it's all in one place
so remember the whole point of both of
these examples can I just point out
before you say it that what you've
written there isn't English no it's not
but none of those are actually even
letters the alphabet that we use here's
what I have learned after years of
living with myself I've learned two
things okay one I don't have any choice
about that and two you don't have much
choice you have more Choice than I do
but I I have some sympathy for you in
this regard but the other thing is that
when I write notes to myself the only
question they're not going to be
readable they're not going to be English
they're not going to be defensible to
anyone else the question is at the point
that I need to go to the note do they
convey enough that I can reconstruct my
way back to whatever it was I was trying
to say
um and in this case I think so yeah it
hasn't been that long that's that's the
key to doing it is you want to write the
note and then find it within five
minutes usually that's short enough
um written language is just just a
Brilliant Invention that uh at some
point
I'm not all that compelled today you
know I think written language is great I
just don't think English should have
been one of them
um but that's the problem yeah okay yeah
English becomes crazy when you start to
write it down for one thing they're all
the doubled words of that that's drives
me crazy does it yeah
um
oh it is because in speech you can
distinguish between the two that's but
on paper you're just stuck with the fact
that it's the same ASCII symbols
repeated
so you want intonation introduced into
the written language and the way you do
that is by not writing it and speaking
it yeah
um I'm glad we had this conversation I
am too we are getting to the limits of
my of the time period in which I can
skill but you don't think that's
intentional on my part it might be you
may end up proving your point here
um okay no I I actually I actually can
read the first word I just don't know
what's on the second line the first word
is model the first word is model on the
second word is DNA and then the third
word is got it it's attenuated you don't
say yeah I do say no I do so okay um
uh okay so what I wanted to just wrap
this up with is the following thing
the fact of having and we're lucky that
it happened on camera
because that means that it's not just
our say so we could go back and we could
find the presentation of the model but
the fact of having models
discussed early that then predict actual
physical phenomena later on
or predict the revelation of evidence in
the case of the second model here the
idea that maybe there was not an attempt
to reduce the number of coveted deaths
early on
um the fact of having those models means
that the things that get said to us
about why we ended up right so
frequently are now falsified
right the things being you got lucky uh
the broken clocks right two times a day
that's what I think everybody guessed
you guessed and you happen to guess
right but somebody would have guessed
right so this wasn't about Insight it
was about you got lucky congratulations
congratulations right that's sort of the
uh the Scott Adams version of things
right
um Sam Harris's version is you were
right for the wrong reasons right well
no when your model turns out to be
predictive of autopsies you're right for
the right reasons sorry just the way it
works then there's the thing that gets
said to us about well
okay you were contrarians and really
what they're saying which frankly I
would almost settle for because it's
good enough to get where we need to go
is yes the what you were officially told
was a hundred percent wrong and a
contrary and therefore didn't fall for
any of it which is not what happened in
this case right you and I were very
careful about we didn't fall into any
known Camp right covet is a dangerous
disease the vaccines are also dangerous
and you're not actually trading one
danger from the other you're actually
compounding them if you get the
so-called vaccine no but so you know I
as you know I have a particular sort of
visceral reaction theory of contrarian
which you know has because it was being
said with affection in some cases like
it was people defending us like well you
know they're concurrence no no no and no
uh in part because
um I disagree that we didn't fall into a
known Camp I understand what you mean by
that which is that uh like oh well the
people who are skeptical of vaccines
also think covet isn't a big deal like
that tended to be a a two opinions that
went together and the people who were
gung-ho on vaccines take covert really
really seriously that was also two
positions that often went together if
you were just voting with ideology if
you were team blue it was the latter if
you were team red it was the farmer and
okay but if like the the camp that we
fell into was Camp science right that
which is which is skepticism of those
things that come at you until you can
assess them using the tools that you
have using as many of the things that
you can see or sense with your own
senses as possible but also then you
know trying it out extrapolating testing
it against other things looking at the
papers
which is what we'll do next looking you
know looking at the papers that are
being trotted out it's like oh well but
science says boom and like okay I'll let
let's let's see what Santa yeah it
doesn't see here this is where the
bodies are buried so you know we did
that kind of thing because we can and we
do and lots of people are trying to do
that and some people you know don't have
a background in you know scientific
jargon enough to make it through the
papers and
um we're more easily compelled and you
know some of those people went
actually no I can't assess that and I
know it
um but I'm going to reject it out of
hand and some a lot of people went you
know what I can't assess that
um and I know that I can't assess it so
I'm just going to accept it out of hand
and both of those positions are
understandable
but neither of them is what we did yep
and and and a lot of people didn't do
that either so it is a known Camp
um which I'm just I'm going to call it
Camp science wow okay
it is it is a distinction not worth not
worth fighting over the fact that it
wasn't a known slate right there's
obviously a method but that's kind of
the point is the method involves
building a model and how do you know
that that model is anything other than a
lucky guess well it's predictive going
forward not just yep not not just was it
predictive in the moment it's predictive
even going forward okay the last thing I
want to say is okay so you've got a
model and then you have reason to
believe that that model is accurate
because it predicts things that are hard
to predict like will this gentleman's
brain show uh lymphocytes on autopsy
yeah okay
and then here is what an extrapolation
looks like not only do we have the
you're going to find damage across the
body and you've only noticed it in the
heart
um because heart failure is so
conspicuous but this is going to be
pathology after pathology that's one
thing the other thing is this
the
transfection technology that the MRNA
vaccines utilized was in one way
absolutely special
and in another way not that special
and it is the distinction between the
special and the Not Special that tells
us how to evaluate the relative risks
which we did correctly okay everybody
who is coming to realize how dangerous
these vaccines are and were
has focused on the MRNA vaccines right
they are most dangerous why is that well
you and I said early on that the number
of Novel features involved in the MRNA
vaccines was by far the highest and
therefore even things like the DNA
vaccines which are truly novel the DNA
vaccines in this case the adenovirus the
adenovirus Specter vaccines right even
those which are highly novel right that
had not been done before but even those
are less novel by virtue of the fact
that instead of using uh lipid
nanoparticle coats which are completely
untargeted they borrowed targeting from
a pre-existing virus that had an
evolutionary history that therefore
would have limited the places that are
transfected to a smaller number of
tissues so not safe but much safer I
would also point out and we we did we
were
when asked both by friends and family
and and on air sometimes in the Q a
um you know if if you have to which one
would you do and in the US here the
option was J J right and and that turned
out to be correct in Spades the pristine
stable Ben work shows uh a slight
all-cause mortality benefit for the DNA
version I don't know whether that will
hold up over the long term because of
course pathologies will eat away at that
but nonetheless the point is you've got
a spectrum of Hazard the MRNA
LNP vectored transfection agents are the
maximally novel least targeted of all
okay second you have the DNA
adenovectored
vaccines which are highly novel but have
some sort of targeting that would have
come from some virus that would have had
some interest in keeping you on your
feet right probably a pretty good
interest so they would not transfect
nearly as indiscriminately and then
there are the best vaccines that we have
right which are attenuated virus
vaccines why are attenuated virus
vaccines the best vaccines that we have
because they trigger a proper not very
serious infection that then causes the
immune system to have the proper
reaction to an infection it's like a
little practice infection so that you
don't get the real infection right is
that cost free no because the exact
thing that I've said this model where
your own cells spot uh what they regard
to be as infected tissue and Target it
that will happen in an attenuated virus
vaccine and it will happen in the Adeno
Vector virus vaccine what is so
different is the completely
indiscriminate nature of the of the
lipid nanoparticle targeting or lack
thereof so anyway
overarching message here is
product of Sciences models the utility
of models is that once you have reason
to believe that they are accurate based
on the fact that they predict things you
can extrapolate from them and here are
uh
two different
extremely important extrapolations that
come from with the model that you and I
develop here on air right one of them is
the damage will be across the body and
have implications well beyond the heart
and the other is that you can look at
virus or vaccine Technologies and you
can specify How likely to be dangerous
they are based on the underlying model
that we've discussed over the course of
many many episodes
indeed
all right
slight switch
um
we didn't quite into where I was
expecting us to so I don't have the
segue I was I was expecting
um
Zach I'm going to ask you to show my
screen off and on here a little bit uh
this week many people will recognize uh
you can show it now uh you are not
giving me any useful video
no no no no I have video from you but
you are extending your screen so it's
not
I see your desktop
I didn't change anything since we set
this up
um
so yeah nothing nothing has changed
since
um and I'm
sorry I don't know what
we are fighting a technical difficulty a
gremlin as it were
and uh just goes on and on and on is it
possible you can
so we can set this up while he's uh
sorting the tech no that's the that's
the setup it's just a little Preamble um
which we can totally skip
for me on your computer so I think
something's just Frozen or something
well you know I do have a new computer
on order
I would recommend restarting but you're
going to lose a lot of stuff so I don't
know
I can't get it to give me anything
useful right now okay well we're gonna
do this without me showing my screen at
all
um it's unfortunate
I guess I can just unplug this then I
don't need that
um okay so this week and I'll link these
things in the show notes this week NBC
famously
um put out this headline immunity
acquired from a covert infection is as
protective as vaccination against severe
illness and death study fines
okay so they are citing a Lancet article
which I have actually not spent any time
with yet
um and my first reaction to this was
well it's about F and time right
and uh
in response some number of people point
out that
uh
Mother Jones remember Mother Jones I
loved that magazine I loved it more than
I loved the New York Times and Mother
Jones has fallen farther and harder
Mother Jones back in May of 2020 had a
headline anti-vaxxers have a dangerous
Theory called natural immunity now it's
going mainstream
quote your body is an amazing being it
knows how to take care of itself
okay so that was Mother Jones wow
incredible I hope that that woman has an
immune system that is intact but she
doesn't seem to believe in it the woman
who wrote this amazing that's amazing
right and then
um when I look when I search the New
York Times for natural immunity
um as you know as the phrase natural
immunity with the quotes I get a
December 5th 2020 hit uh natural
immunity from kova is not safer than a
vaccine
uh so that's just the that's the
conclusion and then the second hit for
natural immunity when I look in the New
York Times this week after NPC has
revealed
um the results of this Lancet article I
have a hit from August 29 1954.
science in review man's natural immunity
to disease may be bolstered by two
recent discoveries
now if you do scroll down in the natural
immunity stuff you do find a couple more
things from the pandemic but it's all
about how natural immunity is basically
an anti-vaxxers creation Okay so
we have this article out of the Lancet
this week which again I have not um
I have not spent time with but one of
the things that happens
uh as a result of the NBC of NBC putting
out a headline like this is that people
will put in the responses yeah but like
yeah but this paper and so one of the
papers that I saw a few times come up
was this and again apologies I can't I
think if you plug it back in
okay we're gonna try this
um
so let me find a thing that I might want
to show now uh hold on
hold on yep I see your screen
okay I've got the beach ball of death
just hold on a minute
um
that's always fun okay nope
give it a second I guess uh so this
paper uh comes out in
I just don't I've now lost X okay
not working very well
um well let me know you can show my
screen now
so this paper comes out it was published
first online in December of 2022 it was
officially published earlier this year
so uh one zoo at all 2023 published in
the American Journal of Public Health
uh SARS Kobe 2 infection hospitalization
and death and vaccinated in infected
individuals by age groups in Indiana
2021-2022.
it's a it's a big study uh and they
specifically went to look at it's it
would appear
um that they were looking at some of the
same things that the landsat study
that's now being reported on by NBC
we're looking at which is again in the
abstract the objectives to assess the
effectiveness of vaccine-induced
immunity against new infections all
cause emergency department visits and
hospital visits and mortality in Indiana
and Indiana is just because that's where
they had access to this giant giant data
set and so again they're looking at four
things they're they're saying okay we
got people who are vaccinated we've got
people who've had prior uh covet
infections but aren't vaccinated and
we're going to compare
what who does better in terms of getting
infected with covet in the future who
does better in terms of getting
um emergency uh they call it emergency
departments visits it's ER basically
right ER visits
um how about hospital visits which I
think what they mean by that is
hospitalizations
um and and death and mortality so you've
got
these four measures and in my is my
screen not working anymore
I think you're just physically
disconnected over there but you're gonna
need to
um let's just uh just assume it's not
going to work so they have
in this paper
this paper is not brilliantly done at
the um
at the editing level and so they've got
a lot of figures that don't have that
don't have explanations and they've got
a whole section of the of the results
that seems to refer to the wrong figures
and the wrong way but ultimately what I
what I find and this is this is where I
would really like to be able to show you
guys the
uh the the data here is that across all
age groups uh and what and you know what
they what they did was they tried to
basically control for they tried to
match they did what they're calling a
matched cohort design where they looked
at various indicators of health and they
kind of kind of ranked them and some of
their rankings were a little dicey like
uh obesity was you know an issue but not
very big issue and like of course for
covet it's actually a really big issue
so I'm not sure why they ranked things
the way they did but they took this you
know giant data set out of Health
Systems in Indiana in Indiana
um of vaccinate people and this giant
data set um sometimes overlapping in
terms of where they were from what
Hospital Systems they were from of
people who uh are not vaccinated but
have had covid and they say okay we're
not going to compare really sick people
with really not sick people we're going
to try to match uh we're going to try to
to match the cohort
and what they appear to have found is
that with regard to infections just like
with this Lancet paper that again I have
not directly assessed but which was uh
which was promoted on NBC this week uh
you find actually lower lower infection
rates among those who have previously
had coveted than among those who have
been vaccinated considerably lower in
across all of all of the um
age classes however
across all of the age classes for each
of the other three measures that they're
looking at that is to say basically
emergency room visits hospitalizations
and deaths
uh you have higher risk of these bad
outcomes if you only had a case of covet
earlier and it's all cosmetalities
they're not trying to attribute this to
covet or you know to the vaccine
certainly you have a higher risk of er
visits of hospitalizations and of death
uh more than a month but less than the
end of the study out from having had
covid than if you had been vaccinated so
that's what they find and that seems you
know pretty damning of much of what what
it is that we are
much of what we have said about the
vaccines uh and again you know if true
damning of what we have said yeah
exactly and um
again I'd like I'd love to show you all
of all of their all of their data
um but the
the bodies are buried unfortunately
maybe almost literally in in this paper
here
what they have done
is they have taken publicly available
data
and they have said that the two
populations that they have compared is
vaccinated people and people with past
covert infections that weren't
vaccinated
but the only people they have access to
the only records they have access to are
people with records are people who are
in the health system because they had
coveted among that second group so
whereas if you've been vaccinated
against covid you are inherently in the
system as someone who has been
vaccinated against covet because that is
a medical intervention
therefore the entire population of
vaccinated people in Indiana is
potentially included in this in this
data set
the vast number of people who were not
vaccinated against covid and who got it
and didn't seek medical help for it or
who weren't otherwise sick and went to
get care and got a covet test and it was
discovered that they were positive
are not possibly represented in this
analysis
anyone who is unvaccinated and had
coveted and recovered like you this week
like our son Toby this week who took a
at-home test went holy cow that's the
first time I've actually got a positive
test right you got two positive tests
Toby got a positive test and we know
lots of people like that right I didn't
happen to get covered this time but you
know lots and lots of people who are not
vaccinated have gotten coveted because
basically the entire world has gotten
going at this point and the vast
majority of us never go and get an
official test to assess that so what
they have actually done here is they
have compared the population the entire
population of vaccinated people to that
population of unvaccinated people who
got coveted and were sick enough to get
medical care
and by doing that
you then get a result that is not at all
surprising
and which is that okay those people who
had covet and were sick enough to seek
medical care as a result of it or you
know coincident with it
are more likely than the entire
population of vaccinated people which
includes lots and lots of otherwise
healthy people to end up in the ER or
hospitalized or death debt
I'm trying to think of an analogy that
would explain just how insane this
comparison is
and
I mean
I I sat with this paper for a little bit
yeah it's it's extraordinarily badly
written and it's like really we said
this last week too I think or a couple
weeks ago like
if it's like obviously this is a kind of
paper that none no student of ours could
have submitted to us but if a student of
mine had submitted a paper with uh
figures like this
I would have told them they needed to
fix them that I would not even assess it
like this I mean it is it is that bad
the labeling the lack of labeling the
you know the lack of clarity
it is that bad but even you know getting
beyond that okay and saying okay what
the science communication is really bad
maybe the science communication is
really bad because they kind of don't
want you messing about knowing what's
going on or maybe it's just they're just
really bad at science communicating and
the editors of the journal were sleeping
that day who knows right but the science
itself the setup of the study the how
would so we have a question we have a
hypothesis they don't set it up that way
of course but I'm imagining that their
hypothesis was
vaccination is more protective than
previous covid infection in against ER
visits hospitalizations and deaths and
maybe they also had that hypothesis for
um future infections of covet I don't
know but those those were the four
measures that they were looking at and
uh note too that with regard to
um even though they didn't include a lot
of people who are unvaccinated have had
covid in this in this analysis
they still have a result that shows a
greater greater protection from future
covet infections from natural immunity
rather than vaccination so in that way
like this paper is coincident with the
Lancet paper but it's the other stuff
that is remarkable because I I basically
guarantee you this is going to be a
paper that gets trotted out over and
over and over again to demonstrate
the safety and efficacy of these
vaccines and it does nothing of the car
well it is designed to fail
it's impossible to say it's intentional
but it appears intentional if what
you're describing is accurate the
non-comparable nature of the two groups
is so extreme it's like if you wanted to
come if you wanted to say well okay
you know let's say that your country was
at war with another country
and you wanted to figure out you know
the way they did during Vietnam right
um what your casualty rate was right and
the answer is well we've got records of
all of the people in our military uh so
let's just see how many of them have
been hospitalized and then how are we
going to get how are we going to figure
out how the enemy is doing well let's go
check our hospitals and see how many of
their soldiers are in our hospitals and
we'll see it you know whether the
injuries are more severe and it's like
well
you check the hospital right you went to
a population that had you know had been
hit and okay so you know it
there's a lot there's other smaller
problems here like they don't even start
counting they and they say oh well it
takes a while for immunity to to happen
and so we're going to start counting a
month after vaccination or a month after
um covet infection which of course will
guarantee that you miss some of the more
acute vaccine injuries as well yeah
right not all of them by any means but
but the ones that happen fast are going
to be totally missed by this
um but but I think
I think that is a decent analogy I don't
think there's a perfect one like it
really is but I it would be useful I
think for us to come up with as many
ways of describing this as possible like
you've got
you've got a population
just pretend these numbers are even for
the moment just for for ease even though
they won't be you've got a population of
100 people 50 of them are vaccinated and
scope but 50 of them aren't okay
and some some scientists come in and say
we want to figure out
if the vaccine is actually protecting
against future against covet infection
against hospitalization against Dr
visits against death
obviously what you want to do is you
want to compare the 50 people who were
vaccinated to the 50 people who weren't
but
the people who have come in and have
decided okay we want to figure out the
answer to this question it turns out
don't have access to some of the 50
people who weren't vaccinated because
they weren't vaccinated and therefore
they weren't seeking that sort of
medical intervention
well what do we know then okay some
people who ended up with covid and
that's this wasn't quite perfect so a
suit that sort of assumes that the
entire background rate is that
everyone's had coveted I guess
um some number of the people who end up
with covet who aren't vaccinated are
sick enough that they get medical
treatment okay cool we'll take those
we'll compare those people and let's
call it 10 10 of the 50. that's high 20
of the of the people who didn't get
vaccinated end up with and who have
covet end up with a bad enough to seek
medical help no way it's that high but
let's just keep it that way for ease of
ease of numbers we've now got 10 people
that you're comparing to the whole 50
over here and those 10 people have
already been selected for
not doing very well in the face of this
disease is that because of something
else well the authors of the study will
say no we try to control for that maybe
but
you didn't control for everything did
you and the fact is that you pulled from
a small sliver of the population that
you claim to have pulled from a small
sliver of the population and the vast
majority of us out here who are not
vaccinated against covid and have had it
and did just fine and never went to the
hospital to get tested
aren't represented in this comparison
therefore the comparison is not
legitimate
okay I want to comment this
the degree to which this failure to
science properly I had not I had not
shared this no it's so stunning that the
point is this is this is malpractice
it's not only malpractice you know it's
one thing maybe you suck at science and
you would propose such a thing maybe
you'd get to the point of running such a
study but the idea this is a
peer-reviewed
study and nobody caught the fact that
this is you're not you can't do this and
the point is look
there's a distinction we used to talk
about this a lot as professors to our
students there's a distinction between
two kinds of error right you've got
random error and you've got systematic
error and it sounds like systematic
error would be better right because
random error who knows what's in it
right but in fact the point is random
error is okay you can deal with random
error by having a larger data set it
will swamp out the error the signal will
overwhelm the noise and big data set
here like random error is going to be
okay right yeah
systematic error where you have a bias
in the direction of you know who who
pray tell who was in their natural
immunity category uh people who were
sick enough to go to the hospital right
and I guess so that's that's a let me
just let me just make sure I'm being
very very careful here I don't know they
were hospitalized people who were sick
enough to end up with a positive covet
test that was in the system right okay
and so they might have they might have
been in the hospital for something else
they like you know there's going to have
been some number of people who just had
it latent and actually The Cove it
didn't have anything to do with the fact
that then they got hospitalized for
something else right you've got a
spectrum of people all the way from uh
went to the hospital and died of covid
to you know asymptomatic right right and
the point is if you were
sampling method excludes anybody who was
asymptomatic and therefore there wasn't
a test or whatever right and explicitly
will not exclude anyone from the
vaccinated group right no one yes I I
don't know how to make it obvious how
bad the the bias in the systematic bias
in the study is and how much it means
that there's actually there's nothing to
read in the tea leaves there once you've
got a system that is systematically
biased in this way the point is it just
simply invalid right you're not there's
no recovering it and you know we see
this in we see this kind of error and at
all you know just like with your bank if
your bank makes a dozen errors and half
of them go in your direction maybe
there's just incompetence at your bank
if your bank makes a dozen errors and
they all go in the bank's favor then
whatever the mechanism underlying it is
the point is it's an unfair Bank
okay and that right there is a
distinction between if half of them go
in One Direction half in another or you
know even if it's like nine
eight four maybe it's random error right
but if they all go in One Direction at
some point you have a stronger and
stronger indication of that systematic
error and you owed your money back right
and you know it's it's a testable model
going forward as you know does the
slight bias in your favor in the error
is reverse then that's a random
phenomenon if it just gets more and more
biased from the bank's favor that tells
you what's going on but we've seen So
Much Monkey Business and it all goes in
the same direction right you've got the
studies of early treatment drugs like
Ivermectin which have lots of cryptic
ways especially in the most recent ones
the ones that have been so highly touted
you have the systematic mechanism for
underdosing those who are most
vulnerable to the Disease by capping the
dosage you know uh for at 90 kilograms
so it stops being uh scaled to to body
mass right that is a systematic error
introduced designed to make the drug not
look uh effective also
the crazy way that you know whether you
were vaccinated or unvaccinated and
therefore your outcome as a result of uh
you know
um in an all-cause mortality if you
count people who've been vaccinated but
haven't gotten two weeks out from their
vaccination date as unvaccinated you
systematically bias these studies when
the point is all you really care about
is somebody who's deciding whether or
not to get injected is do my likelihood
does my likelihood of making it go up if
I get it and the point is that includes
the two weeks right after you got it if
you're more vulnerable for two weeks and
then less vulnerable after then the
answer is the result in terms of
vulnerability is an integration of those
two things you can't systematically
exclude it so
what we see is again and again I would
call this a study not designed to be
read
right well and that's actually
completely consistent with the um like I
this is going to sound like hyperbole
but I think I've never seen figures this
bad
like it it it is stunning and within the
paper itself they confuse themselves and
they're talking about the wrong parts of
it like
you've got like 87 authors no it's more
like seven or something but you know
you've got a bunch of authors on this
very important paper and you you
couldn't even label your figures much
less accurately so yes I I think I think
it was designed not to be read and also
in you know in the original most of the
figures are even in the supplementary
materials they're not even in the paper
um those once you find them and figure
out what they actually mean and put it
together are actually readable but the
one that's in the paper is like tiny and
you have to like expand it and then it's
kind of fuzzy like what is going on here
so
a paper designed not to be read is a
paper that will cause busy academics
journalists whoever looks at it to look
at it and say looks like a scientific
paper to me it's got numbers read the
abstract okay I guess this is what it
means oh they used a master cohort
that's good that's good I know what that
means that so anyway let me just like
matched cohort is fantastic of course
because you know like so
you know when you were trying to compare
two populations you can be like okay we
got
um these people over here and you got
these people over here and let's just be
like are they different or you can say
okay we have we're sampling from the
entire population over here a and the
entire population over here B and but
the comparisons we want to make are
actually one to one we're going to do
individual level comparisons and so
we're going to control as much as
possible for the kinds of differences
between people that might matter for the
purposes of this study and so that also
allows you if you have you know a
population a that's you know a third
bigger than population B like actually
we're just we're going to compare these
two and we're going to match them person
to person and we're gonna we're gonna
see what we get
um but that requires that you actually
pull from the entire population that
you're claiming to pull from which they
did not do what my point is
there is a mechanism for introducing
things that flatter somebody with a
little knowledge right not somebody
who's completely in the dark about
statistics but somebody who knows enough
to know that matched pairs would be a
good thing to do or magic cohorts right
and so the point is oh
I get a gold star for knowing what that
is in fact I'm going to put it in my
article right oh they used a you know a
matched uh system whatever yeah so and
you know the point is this is a
mechanism for getting people to turn
down their skepticism because once
you've been flattered that you know
these course and statistics that you
took prepared you to say a little
something about the statistics they used
in their analysis right you feel good
about this study you're rooting for it
and you feel like oh and they know what
they're doing oh good right oh good
thank you yeah oh it's even better than
it might have been right
um and the point is no it's garbage and
the real question is anybody who thinks
that peer review has a value has a lot
of explaining to do yes when a paper
that actually you know there's one in
the uh the earlier Ivermectin literature
in which they literally reversed the two
groups right they concluded that
Ivermectin had no value because they had
simply swapped data sets between uh
treatment and control right it's like
you can't get a worse error than that so
anyway the idea of if peer review had a
value which it doesn't but if it did
that value would be in finding obvious
errors in papers which those who have
tested peer review have discovered
actually it's not effective at and very
often it introduces errors that weren't
there in the first place yep
so anyway yeah this is uh this is
mind-blowing
um I still I'm hoping that at some point
the absolutely correct analogy will Dawn
on one of us
um but you cannot sample from those
people who have triggered a medical
record that's not the same thing as we
vaccinated a bunch of people and
therefore have all their records you
know irrespective of anything else yeah
I mean yeah so but I'm just going to say
it and again probably very much the same
way I've already said it but
the question they're trying to address
is does vaccination or previous
infection protect you better against
future covet infection
hospitalizations visits the ER and death
great question important question a
question that we need answers to
absolutely
the way to answer that question
is to look at people who are vaccinated
and people who are not vaccinated but
have had coveted which frankly in that
second set people who were not
vaccinated have had coveted that's
almost everyone who's not been
vaccinated at this point because almost
the entire world said covet at this
point there may be a few people who
still haven't but
that aside
what you cannot do in comparing those
two groups is say okay we'll take all of
group a vaccinate group
and we'll take a subset of Group B
who got into the health system with a
positive covet test
and just like I would ask our audience
to consider vaccinate or not
when you did have covet because you
probably did maybe you've had it twice
or three times or five times right when
you did have coven
did you go and to the ER and get a test
did you go to your doctor and get a test
did you or did you not test at all but
we're just so certain because you lost
your sense of smell or did you take one
of the home tests that the post office
was sending out to people for free for a
while right
chances are
that you did one of those other things
and if you did end up with a positive
test that was in the health system again
vaccinated or not
my prediction is and this is just not a
risky prediction so that's because you
were just that sick yeah as opposed to
oh boy okay God it finally happened okay
I got you know I gotta I gotta treat
this I gotta sleep I gotta yeah I got
gotta get better I'm gonna do that at
home so I'm not gonna go to the hospital
where there's a bunch of sick people and
where I might get sicker
all right I want to push back on one
thing okay it should be important to
study the question of
um which of these things is more
protective right the VAC the so-called
vaccine uh or prior infection I mean I
think we know the answer well we do but
it should be important but in some ways
we have a holdover idea that is
important from a period in which we
believed much more strongly in the idea
that these things actually prevented
people from Contracting covet the idea
that what you are really doing is
compounding the risks of the two things
and you are not choosing between them
because getting the vaccine doesn't
prevent you from getting covered and
maybe there's a complex story in which
it affects what kind of covet you get
but but the point is it should be
important but it isn't right what we
have is a very damning video in which a
much younger Anthony fauci says you know
of course natural immunity is better
than any vaccine everybody knows that
right that's effectively what he says In
that clip that circulates and the point
is okay yeah we all do know that that is
the natural
order of things when it comes to uh to
viruses
but in this case what we have is a
confusing situation in which it really
isn't clear a there's all the
shenanigans that have been played with
you know you're unvaccinated until
you've been vaccinated for two weeks and
therefore which category were you
counted in there's all of this stuff and
so really the point is if he died a week
after being vaccinated with covid that
might have been a covet death right and
yeah exactly so the
um
the right thing to do at this point
given the I believe artificial
complexity of the picture right where we
are given information that's hard to
parse you you know oh that person died
unvaccinated no they were vaccinated
they just weren't two weeks post
vaccination right if they're going to
play those kinds of games the only game
in town here really are measures that
are ungameable right like all cause
mortality right
you're in category a did your all-cause
mortality go up right that tells you I
don't need to know the mechanism right
what I need to know is that this did or
did not benefit me from the point of
view of staving off death right it's a
simple measure and because it's a simple
measure it is much harder to game and uh
anyway I think that that's where we are
in part because as we have said multiple
times science is the most powerful way
for figuring out what's true but it's a
fragile mechanism right it requires that
you do it right and when there are so
many people with so many perverse
incentives to do it incorrectly to reach
conclusions that are rewarding because
somebody wants to you know have a paper
to wave right the point is no it's not
going to work science doesn't work under
those circumstances you need people who
actually have the as their highest
priority discovering what is true
whether or not it flatters their
preconceptions and uh we're just not in
that environment we're in an environment
of and list scientific sophistry
that's right
let's um
let's just say a few things about stigma
and shame well good
um
no really actually and I think there is
a segue here which I didn't I didn't see
which is that
uh
one of the
very few I think Silver Linings
um from the public health response to
this last three years
has been that people are more aware of
the risk of their putting others at when
they walk out into the world while sick
yeah and uh
it is it is it it got really ridiculous
for a while like there were there were
moments I remember
being like a restaurant and having
something stuck in my throat and being
like Oh my God must not cough because I
will get the look of death from every
other person in this restaurant right uh
and so you know there like with
everything it can be taken too far but
should there be a stigma
against you taking your productive cough
out into the world and into other
people's spaces yes yeah there should
there should and should you know could
people use shame to help create that
stigma
yeah now will there be things that we
might be interested in shaming people
for you know having stigmas about now
that will change over time
might it turn out that uh that we
weren't right about things of course
so the amazing Lionel Shriver
uh wrote a piece this month in unheard
called Western societies built on stigma
here's just one little uh one little
excerpt my point being that stigma isn't
always bad it can attach to particular
conduct for good reason Collective
disapproval is a powerful tool for
encouraging Behavior that's in the
collective interest more recent
campaigns to remove the stigma clean to
overtly destructive conduct are
therefore questionable that includes the
Crusade to embrace fat Pride which wages
a two-pronged war on conventional
assumptions about both Aesthetics and
health
so
you know spot on she's she's so good I
just I haven't I haven't read many of
her novels but I've been
um
reading a number for essays lately and
she's just incredible this is again
Lionel Shriver
uh who yes changed her name apparently
as like a 15 year old because even
though she never thought she was a man
no uh but was uh tired of being sort of
associated with girly stuff so uh and
she and uh so she talks a lot in this
essay about
um about fat shaming
um it puts me in mind too of the thing
now that people say Kink shaming right
and
um
and I was going to show but maybe it's
better that I don't
um
an online commentator uh who's fairly
well known said
this this week well
um so there's a move to normalize Auto
auto gynophilia autogonophilia being
broadly
um
I hope I get this exactly right but
basically the condition in which a man
basically gets off so sexually on
um on the idea of being a woman and um
he can enhance that sense by dressing up
as a woman and it has been proposed I
think it was at Ray Blanchard who first
introduced this term to
um to all of us and who proposed that
this is actually one of the things
um this is this is one of the things
that is what modern trans is right is
that these are actually aragonophiles
um
who don't who don't actually think that
they are women but are um they get off
on it they're getting off and they're
enhancing their erotic lives by doing
this so this week it was revealed that
Leah Thomas the swimmer dude who beat
all those women at swimming because when
he'd been swimming as a man he wasn't
beating men and so he started swimming
as a woman because apparently you can do
that now
um
it was revealed that he was he's been
active in a bunch of Auto got a failure
um forums online
uh and you know at one level like okay
like whatever he was still cheating like
I I don't know why we care really like
how he got there but he shouldn't have
been swimming against those women in a
competition and by doing so he was
cheating and it made the entire
competition
um not a competition
um but we have this um
this online commentator saying it's
perfectly legitimate to debate the
fairness of male to female trans folk
competing on female sports teams
shaming hashtag aragonophile how to kind
of philia however is unfair
AGP Auto I can't say it auto gynophilia
appears to be simply another atypical
sexuality that people do not ask for and
cannot change
now the same person I should say has
made similar arguments about pedophilia
yep
um
so obviously
obviously in this case you can make
analogous claims like
he just felt like raping people
can't change it
like he's just kind of a rapey guy
and obviously we can't let him do it
but you don't want to shame him you
can't change it it's just who he is
it exactly is a kink
when did Kink get to become this thing
that we're like oh a protected category
yeah like Kink yeah
what the actual hell what is what is
going on here and and furthermore
why is it that Kink is like elevated to
this protected category that's exactly
right and
anytime there is any implication of
shame or stigma
that can be dismissed and the person who
is using it or is in any way alluding to
that being useful
as effectively an evolved strategy by
which to allow all of us to live
together in peaceful Harmony
that's the thing like oh you can't well
now I can't talk to you you're Kink
shaming you took that protected category
which never should have been protected
at all and he used a technique that
we're not allowed to use we don't shame
people well actually you know what we we
do and we have and as Lionel Shriver
writes about she's specifically writing
about stigma and not shame but they are
closely related and
as she points out in this piece Western
Society is actually built on this this
is this is how
how we enforce social norms
is by stigma not entirely not the only
way that we do it but it is one of the
ways that we do
so I I haven't read the piece yeah um it
is 100 obvious from an evolutionary
perspective that but that shame and
stigma are evolutionary adaptations
right there is something to be concerned
about in the weaponization of these
things of course right I mean like we we
all remember all of us who saw it the
Game of Thrones scene where you know the
horrible Queen Cersei Cersei yep um uh
is you know is has her walk of shame
she's naked and she's being pelted and
such and she's done something horrifying
I don't remember what but it still feels
appalling right
um yeah I don't know what to do with
that one because of course the character
is so morally compromised right to begin
with but nonetheless look we were all
shamed those of us who did not want to
get these so-called vaccines were all
shamed that was weaponization of an
evolved trait against people who were
actually just looking out for their own
medical well-being and
um anyway obviously that's not
legitimate but the idea
that shame itself is invalid is
preposterous
um
again I didn't read this article but my
sense is never mind Western Civilization
right Human Society is founded on shame
and the I I saw the same tweet that you
did from this uh very troubling person
who would defend pedophilia and was now
defending autogynophilia as
immutable the person didn't ask for it
so who are you to you know blah blah
blah no
a there's an assumption built into this
and yes I'm sure there is a whole shoddy
literature that will be used uh to
pretend that this is actually the result
an empirical result but the idea
that your desires your kinks whatever
are not sensitive to whether or not they
are viewed as shameful whether people
whose shame causes them you know I mean
look we you know we've now had a
secretary of nuclear waste management
who was a pup Handler which is obviously
a kink involving something very closely
psychologically related to bestiality
right I'm I'm super comfortable shaming
pup handling right Pub handling and the
point is Pub handling is presumably the
gateway to uh actually getting sexually
involved with animals so whatever the
point is there are biological reasons
that bestiality is viewed as shameful
should we be playing with that boundary
right no we should not be playing with
that boundary right we likewise we can
say exactly the same thing
with respect to incest you know could
you make an argument for tolerating
incest in cases where you're not going
to find any deleterious recessives that
get doubled and cause birth defects we
couldn't be playing with this boundary
in the first place the point is the so
so I mean so the argument will come back
like well but the boundaries inherently
fuzzy because you know incest is an easy
one to describe the Border being fuzzy
like full shibs no you know second
cousins oh um right so you know where
where is the boundary and that's going
to differ by situation and culture and
you know opportunity but you and I used
to teach all the time that where is the
boundary is not a valid argument against
a principle yes right yes but you seem
to be arguing about you should we be
playing with the boundary which suggests
that you can see that you can find the
boundary no my point is like everything
else you know how much you know how
close to the cancer would you like to
get during the surgery I'd like to get
far enough away from it that you didn't
miss any right yeah where should we have
the boundary in our you know tolerance
for incest uh really far away from
incest right really far away from any
place that it has impacts you know how
free should we be to uh play with sexual
violence you know not really free at all
I really just don't want to see it
legitimized you know pedophilia huh you
know how young is too young uh well how
about just stay the [__] away from
people who are too young for you and
let's talk about what hard boundary we
should leave in the law and what kinds
of really serious penalties we should
inflict on people who violate that uh
that age uh restriction you know this is
it's obvious the point is what is
important is the functioning of
civilization and the protection of
people and the way you do that is you
figure out where the boundary is far
enough away from the Intolerable
behavior that there's no danger of
Crossing into it right and so anyway I
I'm not interested in hearing about
um
the problem of Shame yes shame
misapplied is bad right uh yes yelling
if it's too loud or in an inappropriate
context is bad uh yes skipping a period
too long between meals is bad but the
point is none of these things are
inherently bad and people are just it's
sophistry all the way down they are
taking instances in which something is
misapplied and using it to invalidate
the whole category because there's
something they want to do and you know
in this case it's you know something
that gets them off but it's not
civilization is not theirs to screw up
yeah
no and uh to the degree that a lot of a
lot of these arguments like you know it
appear autogonophilia appears to be
simply another atypical sexuality that
people do not ask for cannot change
that sounds like a kind of libertarian
argument and uh there will there were
people there will be people who should
have said well you know who could it
harm
you know
a not our responsibility to figure that
out
but B
the number of inroads being made to
protected women's spaces
with the argument that some
tiny minority of in this case
um
people engaging in sexual kink
that it's their rights it's the tiny
number of people over here with sexual
Kinks who oh by the way all happen to be
men get to override the rights of oh
half the human population
yeah no
we're done like
it's It's gotta stop and somehow we need
the proper tools to talk about what's
really going on because undoubtedly
there's a parameter in here that should
be called reinforcement right where it
may be that I I bet it isn't even
any genetic predisposition at all my
guess would be it is the accident of
early experience that causes somebody to
have some sexual Focus until it's off
totally and the question is does it get
reinforced enough that it becomes a
fetish and I think the technical
definition is that it's somehow required
to get off right that's where it
fetishes yeah
but the idea is how does something end
up in that category through some process
of reinforcement where some initial
initial interest that wasn't okay has
been uh fed upon probably by uh people
making money off of uh let's see what
weird Kinks You know haven't been met by
some Supply so we can make money by
feeding them right so you find some
really Fringe stuff and you feed it and
you make money and then the point is
okay you might even create it right but
then okay you've now reinforced a the
idea that it's normal yes you reinforced
be the person's sexual focus on this
thing and the point is and then some
pseudo researcher is going to say
oh well it's just you know they didn't
ask for it yeah so given the online
forums and social media and advertising
separately are doing all of this
positive reinforcement of ridiculous
Behavior the idea that the rest of us
aren't allowed to employ some negative
reinforcement no not only are we allowed
to It's Our obligation This is Our
obligation you've got online and social
media communities who are riling
themselves up into a state of kinkery
and advertisers of various sorts who are
helping if they happen to create the
products that that are related to that
kangaroo and
there's the all the rest of us out here
many of whom aren't paying attention to
this but all the rest of us I think
you've nailed the word we are actually
not just allowed to but obligated to
engage in negative reinforcement no no
that's not that's not interesting that's
not good I don't care if you think you
get off on that that's not okay stop it
yeah now uh I would add one more piece
of the puzzle which my my guess would be
Shriver didn't didn't find but this I
mean most of this that we're talking
about wasn't in her piece yeah
most of
um
the most fundamental version of Fame as
an adaptation has to do with the fact
that [__] stinks
[__] stinks so that people cannot help
but be repulsed by it right and that
means that you as a producer of same
have to be very careful about how you do
it where you do it what you do after
wash your hands this that and the other
so that you do not find yourself shunned
by people who will be acting on yes a
crude proxy for a later to be discovered
microbiological reality of you're a
hazard if you smell like that right and
so and shunned shamed stigmatized
because you're literally a vector of
disease right or you could be you're
depending on what you mean that's your
disease and the point is you know what
else it is it's a training program right
the point is if you smell like that and
people shun you you might learn to
change your behavior so you no longer
smell like that you become a non-hazard
to people and they might welcome you
back into polite society and so the
point is that's an exact model of what
should be going on here right see the
non-vector you want to see in the world
right so oh uh okay you're applying for
the job of Secretary of nuclear waste
disposal and you want to use your
platform as a as a governmental official
to uh broadcast your uh dog sex
fantasies is that right sorry
um that's inconsistent with your role as
a public official why don't you come
back when you've got that good and cured
right I mean so I mean there's
there's obviously a line here
where that particular person I don't
remember his name Sam Brinton Sam
Britton no longer in the position not
for the Kink but for repeatedly stealing
handbags from airports is that right
luggage luggage oh just like otherwise
it wasn't ladies purses okay uh
okay so he's no longer in the position
but
there is a question of course about if
you know so so many of these things are
wrapped up in an exhibitionism which
makes it easy it's just easy like nah
you showed us because you wanted us to
see and now we're going to talk about
and we're going to shame you for it but
if somehow he had been
a
at home
behind locked doors
with consenting
dog people
um you know men dressed as dogs I do
this thing yep I don't talk about it I
don't share it with you uh you know to
to what degree is what used to be the
military's position on
um on gay people in in the military
don't ask don't tell relevant here so
like it's only relevant in one way which
is if we don't know about it it's not
relevant to your qualifications if
you're highly qualified at dealing with
nuclear waste and you don't know what
you're doing in the bedroom then it's
not relevant to that question it doesn't
mean so we can't I I agree but there but
the the way that you frame the what I
was responding to was you said like you
you get that thing cured and then come
back it's like well
you put that in front of us like you
just put that on full display and for
some reason at the moment half the
country is like yay go for it and like
you know that's that's part of the
problem but
if it's never been on display
uh and he was actually competent at the
you know disposing of nuclear waste
safely at the federal level job that he
was actually hired to do and also had
this this Kink
um that he actually kept private
he's not actually obliged to cure that
thing no he is obliged to cure that
thing having nothing to do with his
Federal position he's not obliged in
order to perform the duties of the job
correct correct but you know this is
ultimately the conversation that we have
to have yeah is how much is the argument
that well whatever goes on between my
ears is my business and no one else's
how true is that how true is it that
whatever two consenting adults do in the
bedroom is their business you know
obviously I believe that to a point but
I do I stop believing it at the point
that the idea is
you know what rape role play that's cool
long as you got a safe word and the
answer is look I'm not really
comfortable with how it is that we say
actually that's not okay even if you
have a safe word right I don't know the
answer to that I don't know the answer
to how do we deal you know can rape be
represented in the movie presumably it
has to be right how is that going to be
any different than what consenting
adults do behind closed doors with a
safe word I don't know the answer to
that question but the question I think I
do know the answer to Is is this
actually a healthy process where we turn
where we play with sexual violence such
that it becomes normal right that's not
okay so assuming assuming a heterosexual
role play there both people
are worse off
are are
going to be and and less fulfilled
sexually less fulfilled exactly
presumably but even if they're not the
point is the normalization of that
behavior right turning rape into a fun
game right means that some people are
going to get raped who wouldn't have
otherwise because somebody turned it
into a fun game and then somebody who
wasn't capable of managing the border
between game and reality got a hold of
that thing and so the point is you're
actually talking about rape victims yeah
right you may not be talking about it in
the bedroom in question but you are
talking about it somewhere and the
question is you know well look we do let
people drive and people are going to die
on the highway so there's some level of
tolerance for harm that comes from
things that are productive but you know
in the case of something like uh the
normalization of rape as a kink right
where's the upside yeah no and that's
you know that's that's why I bring it up
here because you know no one is yet
saying rape is kink oh boy I don't think
that's true at all okay then I brought
it up thinking that it was new you know
whatever it was 15 minutes ago or so but
you know if
phytokinophilia
and pedophilia and violence sexual
violence
are all things that are somehow now a
protected category and to speak ill of
them is shaming and bad that's backwards
land like we we landed in a space where
um you know the conversations that
you're trying to get us to have with in
this conversation are um
are challenging and I think almost no
one will show up at exactly the same
place and that you know you and I don't
show up at the exactly the same place
but you know and and we and we can try
to figure out where we do but
um
but the place where we started that's
not nuanced right right like that that's
easy like the the like what
how Okay is like how free is your head
actually yep and how free can your head
be and
um how free should it be if we are
simultaneously trying to uh trying to
free the individual and live in a
society uh is challenging uh but
um exalting Kinks to protected classes
isn't that's actually easy well it is we
shouldn't do that it is the Hallmark of
us moving in the wrong direction so
again yeah freely acknowledge that I
don't know how in a free Society you
draw the proper line but I would also
point out that in some ways
shame is the answer here right how free
should you be to use the toilet and not
wash your hands
well at the moment what we've got as far
as I understand it is a rule that if
you're employed in a food selling
establishment there are legal
requirements and if you're not you're
apparently free to do as you like right
I don't really think you should be free
to do as you like and frankly there is a
informal mechanism whereby all of us are
disgusted by the person who walks out of
the stall and bypasses the sinks and
then go touches the doorknob right and
the point is that's not a law but it
does mean hey that thing that you just
did is not okay and shame is the way to
do it without having it that's the extra
legal way to do it right like that's
what we have that's the tools that we
have without having to take everything
into the law which we no one wants it's
not good for everything to be at the
level of the law uh agreed and so you
know
this needs some kind of a we're going to
be here again on various different
topics but the point is we are
rediscovering an ancient mechanism yeah
right the fact that that ancient
mechanism
uh gives us all kinds of evidence of how
it works right the the stinkiness of
[__] that's a built-in feature designed
to keep you safe from a microbe that
nobody knew was a microbe at the point
that right that evolved right there was
no language Well it can't be bad if you
if you don't know the mechanism of
action hey you sound like Claire Layman
and you know most of the Yahoo
scientists who were talking about what
you could and could not know during this
pandemic yep right totally but yes the
idea that we have an informal that most
dare you I'm sorry
you were doing an impression at the time
I didn't know I was I have no idea she
said anything like that but
uh we won't go into it but okay uh
anyway I do think
um
we we have landed on something
vitally important I must say everything
that we have experienced during the
pandemic has spooked me more and more
about governmental power yes right it is
not I have not lost any sight of the
fact that there are certain processes
that just absolutely have to be
government regulated or were in huge
trouble but I fear the power to regulate
now because I've seen what happens with
it right but
the idea that we have a whole bunch of
tools below the level of legal
regulation you know it's not just some
giant Gap whatever is not uh legally
forbidden is totally cool right the
point is that space is where we actually
have to get along with each other right
and it isn't about the law and if you
push these boundaries you will force it
to be so yeah don't yeah that's that's
good that's good all right I think we
did it
all right I think uh I think we're at
the end when you say we did it
civilization has saved or not yet I
don't I don't think we did that yet
we'll give something to do next week
yeah we're working on it okay so we're
gonna take a 15-minute break and um
we'll be back with a live q a shortly
you can ask questions for the Q a at
darkhorsesmissions.com
and and also right now if you're
interested in joining the private
monthly q a that we have which is really
fun uh it's a smaller group so we
actually pay attention to the chat and
engage with the chat as it happens uh
you can ask questions for that at my
patreon right now and that q a will be
next week uh in the meantime until we
see you next be good to the ones you
love eat good food and get outside be
well everyone
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]